packed their [ __ ] up and they were out i
don't know where they are they're
probably in this mouth
they've moved into that neighborhood
yeah
that's why it looks all horse-like yeah
but did you really get veneers at 14
yeah i got vineyards at 14. wait wait
were your
teeth bad back then yeah well i i drink
a lot of soda i eat a lot of popsicles
right i got a lot of cavities hot out
here babe yeah yeah i mean
you know by the pool just eating
fudgicals and uh
yeah they're kind of discolored and
small and my mom i didn't know what
veneers were and my mom's like we're
gonna get you the new years today and i
was like all right
you know i go to the dentist and the way
they do it is they shave down your teeth
to a nub
yeah to a nub and like i didn't know
what they were doing
yeah and they showed me like here's what
your teeth look like now and there's
like these little nubs
what the [ __ ] is going on what if you
wouldn't want
i don't want them this is cool i want
this yeah
no i think i have a little nub teeth
would be cool well look like most people
like hillary duff has veneers right
when i look at her like i always imagine
like down the road she's gonna be like
[ __ ] this
you know [ __ ] these veneers and just
like you know sport the nubs and i think
that should be a movement on its own
totally yeah one broke off recently i
had to get a new one but i was
considering keeping the nub as the
my right incisor i don't know oh so the
veneers are one individual ones
individually yeah so what do they think
they glue
i don't understand how that works how do
they do it so they take the knob so they
take the nub and then they
it's like a cap over your tooth and then
they they glue it on and like then they
like you know seal it with some like
sort of
uh blue light or whatever i don't really
know what it is yeah yeah yeah
but first you know for two weeks after
they gave me the nubs
they had to make the veneers so i had
this like george washington just tray
a block teeth yeah and i went down to
costa rica for like a surf camp you know
and everyone's like dude what the [ __ ]
yeah and i was like she's these huge ass
teeth i'm like i don't know you're
talking about dude
yeah and uh but then i got the real and
uh
yeah they look good dude you know i just
noticed them a little bit
no honestly i didn't think you had
veneers i just thought you had like you
know your mom was a horse or something
you know what i mean
yeah but does that mean
because your mom's probably beautiful in
the night she's the best yeah yeah and
my bad
does that bond us or no
is that a bonding or no yeah i mean i've
been searching for something like the
upper lip situation between us
yeah so let's just let that be that yeah
he called me he was jealous he's like
i'm upset bobby didn't call it anything
about my aesthetics
yeah yeah it's coming dude i just say so
the horse tooth was the thing yeah when
you said horse tooth i was like oh thank
god
yeah yeah yeah so um are you when you're
surfing mm-hmm are you good are you
flying i'm decent yeah
yeah yeah decent i know what i'm doing
but
what i imagine when people are surfing
is
when you ride a tube have you written a
tube
you have how many tubes uh
thousands no probably like 12.